hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the monday morning podcast
for monday
august 9th
2021 what's going on how are ya
how's it going with you
how you hanging in there jesus christ
i got to give a shout out right now
right now to news
junkies
i don't know how you guys do it
i don't know how the [ __ ] you how to
[ __ ] how the [ __ ] do you just sit around
staying informed
look at this [ __ ]
jesus christ like i looked up i you know
i don't feel like i got i didn't really
do much this week
nothing that exciting i gotta talk to
myself for an hour you know what am i
gonna [ __ ] talk about ah let's see
what's in the news
dixie fire mushrooms into second largest
wildfire in california history
dixie fire continues to burn but these
residents are staying
dixie fire rages into northern
california record books
uh
biden's infrastructure bill crawls
towards senate passage is anything
that's a and then i don't know
i don't want to get into all that
politics desantis whoever this guy is
and they have the most grumpiest looking
photo ever this guy
uh
is starting to build his stature in 2024
and uh he says he disagrees on masked
mandates
these kids aren't wearing masks
the amount of people who not only don't
even own a microscope or even have a
pair of scrubs
you know unless they went to some
halloween party who are literally
questioning doctors it's just at this
point it's just hilarious
and what do you know
these [ __ ] pieces of [ __ ] politicians
he knows that that's what his fan base
wants him to do so that's what the [ __ ]
he's gonna do
unbelievable
uh barack obama celebrates 60th birthday
bash
after scaling back guest list because of
covet concerns
slash people who may or may not have
gone to epstein island
uh the taliban has seized two more
provincial capitals in the afghanistan
as the u.s exit nears
not one uplifting story yet uh i guess
trump uh obama turned 60. that part was
good but then he's got to scale back his
guest list
of other [ __ ] murderers and you know
because they don't want to get
sick
sorry
i don't pay attention to the news so
don't listen to me
um trump's acting attorney general
revealed frightening activity at justice
department
uh the rule of law pushing back against
trump's big lie
and then finally the surprise band jimmy
page once called his favorite american
group it's little feet
uh and then there's a boxing match
and then bruins way too early bruins
opening night lineup
uh
roster projections and these are the
ones that says for you
like here's the [ __ ] you should be
paying attention to recommended based on
your interests
oh i did get the trump one that
surprised me the rule of law pushing
back i got a cnn one
after all the things i said about them
that's amazing maybe they're trying to
maybe the robot's trying to win me back
right wing radio host and anti-vaxxer
dies of covet
get the [ __ ] out of here
i gotta read that that's when somebody's
against the helmet law gets on a
motorcycle and cracks his [ __ ] head
open
a right-wing radio host from florida who
publicly criticized vaccines told his
friends to get vaccinated shortly before
he died of covid
all right what is this slate.com who the
[ __ ] is this
get the slightest i'm not reading this
[ __ ]
how do i know that's true that's another
thing too people you have to understand
that there aren't there's no rules of
libel or slander on the internet
you can just basically write whatever
you want and you can put some videos up
and put some ominous music underneath it
and then you know
just sit back and let the mouth
breathers [ __ ] roll in oh whoa look
at that
the world is flat what
um anyway so i'm gonna try to be
uplifting on this podcast
now that i've read all that [ __ ]
negative [ __ ] that's why right there is
why i don't watch the news because there
is a bunch of [ __ ] in there that is
absolutely terrifying that i have
absolutely no power over i cannot
[ __ ] change it
i just i have little battles okay i no
longer drink plastic bottle
water i got my little thermos everywhere
i go
all right
i found when i stay in hotels usually
down at the gym
you can refill it somewhere there
at which point they're gonna get mad and
they'll take that [ __ ] thing out but
if they really had a brain you just
charge me for the water i think that
they should just have like water
stations and everybody has the thermos
like [ __ ] in our canteen like clint
eastwood no spaghetti westerns
you know
maybe that maybe you know what maybe i
shouldn't get so mad at these [ __ ]
cyclists
you know what i mean because they're not
putting fumes into the air but then they
get all hot and sweaty and they're
adding to global warming
uh other good news i weighed in the
other day i was
179.8 i'm into the 170s
although i ate bad last night like a
[ __ ] idiot oh man i found just like
all right
you know
my beautiful little daughter you know
she took a week-long cooking class and
every day she'd come home with stuff
that she made so they made like a loaf
of bread
so i was like ah [ __ ] it i'm gonna make
some french toast with this i haven't
had [ __ ] french toast
in a long time
what was that from the 40 year old
virgin let's get some [ __ ] french
toast
um
and uh i cooked it up and i made it and
it was absolutely delicious but i
screwed up i hit the crack pipe so later
on that night my wife came home
and she's like what do you want to get
to eat it was late night i was like i
don't know you want to get something bad
we haven't eaten bad in like three weeks
she goes all right
she goes you want to do it
i go do what she goes you know i go i'm
not [ __ ] going there
she goes come on you got to go there i
go i'll go to a taco truck
she's like nah i don't feel like getting
mexican tonight so
i go i'm not going to mcdonald's i can't
i can't i'm too old i can't do it can we
at least go to wendy's where it sort of
looks like real meat can i do that
and
she's like who the [ __ ] goes to wendy's
it's like i do
i relate to that little redheaded girl
on the side okay
she still has a dignity as opposed to
that red-headed [ __ ] clown
what's what what's the deal with
redheads the burger king guy sort of a
ginger
what would you guys do if you found out
that redheads
were actually the ones that were running
everything
right that we were the blue bloods i
mean our skin is almost transparent so
you can definitely see our veins
especially during the winter
that's where blue blood came from i
guess
these pasty white people and they'd see
their blue veins
and they used to say that they had blue
blood
i guess
because
like most of these [ __ ] idiots who
don't have a a medical degree who are
speaking with authority
rather than just listening to people who
know what that it's like do you listen
to your mechanic yeah you know what
you're talking about
uh you're missing uh five out of six lug
nuts i i wouldn't go 80 miles an hour
down down the [ __ ]
fake nose
um
yeah they didn't understand that it was
the blood
i guess going uh oh jesus christ now i
can't even explain it i looked it up a
long time ago it's basically you have
oxygenated blood and once your body uses
it up the stuff that has the co2 in it
is when it's coming out i guess when you
exhale it turns blue i'm sorry see this
is why you shouldn't listen to me
this is why you should only listen
to people that have medical degrees what
is that again how does that work i don't
give a [ __ ] i'll forget it i already
looked it up
obviously my brain is like dude you're
you're out of your element here we we're
just gonna stick this information that
you just read and spewed out
back when i did it we're gonna stick it
in a little shoe box
and just add it to the pile of [ __ ] that
you read but didn't quite understand
um so what would you do if redheads were
the real blue bloods right and the way
that we kept you all dumb
was we felt we would we are the people
behind the fast food
and that's why all
of the mascots the ronald mcdonalds the
wendy's
the [ __ ] uh
ronald mcdonald and look at the jack in
the box you're telling me that doesn't
look like me if i shave my beard off
and i stand next to the jack-in-the-box
guy you're gonna tell me you see a
difference
creating a new conspiracy theory theory
here that's how we keep you all
[ __ ] dumb
um and that's why the sun doesn't like
us because we're so negative i don't
know this there's something in there
you know
you throw a little kid in there with
glasses and there's witches you got
yourself like a trilogy
um
yeah so anyway my kids been taking these
classes so we ended up going to [ __ ]
wendy's
and as i pulled in i go you know i'm not
even that hungry anymore but i gotta
[ __ ] it i'll do it
so
my wife ordered smart
you know she got a burger right and i
went in there and i was just like ah you
know first of all i looked at their menu
i'm like
where are the square patties
they used to be the single the double
and the triple where the [ __ ] is it and
they had all this other [ __ ]
the baconator the son of the baconator
the [ __ ] uh
i don't know what all of this [ __ ]
and then the horrifying information next
to it like this is 1100 calories it's
like i know it's bad for me
so [ __ ] dog you can score crack and
it doesn't have a little [ __ ] message
on it
um
anyway
so i pull up to the [ __ ]
the big clown car thing there and if
they go hi the guy goes welcome to
wendy's can i help you
and i said i said to the guy i said how
you doing tonight it was a pause and he
goes
i'm good
i was like that's good to hear you know
i always make sure i say hello to those
people
it's a [ __ ] that's a brutal job even
when you're young you don't give a [ __ ]
and you know
it's your first foray out into the job
[ __ ] world
it's not a fun job you know and all
these nerds who try to make these
[ __ ] tick tock videos of them [ __ ]
with them you know they always feel like
they're getting trolled
one of the dumbest things you could ever
do trolling somebody who's now gonna go
handle your food
um
anyway
so i go uh let me get the number six the
fried chicken sandwich
and uh and i'll get a coke
the guy goes all right
and i bumped it up to the large fry
so i get all this [ __ ] first thing he
does is he hands me the drink which i
swear to god the size i thought was
gonna get like one of those old school
paper like
ones it was a giant plastic [ __ ] cup
which i wish i gave back to him because
that [ __ ] thing's gonna live for 800
to a thousand years in the ocean
just because one night i wanted a burger
with a coke right
[ __ ] i could literally with this
thing i could fill up an above-ground
pool probably in an hour that's how big
this [ __ ] thing was
and it was pepsi too which
this is the worst right
um
so i get all the food and we go back and
i ate that chicken sandwich and it
absolutely [ __ ]
sucked
i didn't like one bite of it it
absolutely sucked and i remember walking
out
my wife was just laughing at me
you know not in a bad way but she goes
was it really that bad like it was
[ __ ] horrible
and i was like i should have got a
burger what was i thinking i mean it's
wendy's they make burgers
you know they're just trying to take a
little bite out of popeyes or [ __ ] uh
what's the other big chick chick-fil-a
you go to chick-fil-a you don't get a
hamburger you go to wendy's
you don't get it you don't get a fried
chicken burger and i completely [ __ ]
up so i did that ate the fries the fries
sucked
the whole [ __ ] thing sucked i sound
like that guy there playoffs
the offense sucked the defense sucked
way sacked
which i think is actually his better
rant
i gotta find this thing
because everybody always quotes him
playoffs
some reason i'm spacing on his name
playoffs there he is
jim mora
i gotta look this up jim
maura
we sucked
oh this is it this is the greatest
[ __ ]
my favorite gym more ever well what
happened was that second game we got our
ass kicked or the second half we just
got our ass totally kicked
we couldn't do diddly two offensively we
couldn't make a first down we couldn't
run the ball we didn't try to run the
ball we couldn't complete a pass we
sucked the second half we sucked we
couldn't stop the run every time they
got the ball they went down and got
points we got our ass totally kicked in
the second half that's what it boiled
down to it was a horse performance in
the second half
i'm totally embarrassed and totally
ashamed
coaching our
coaching did a horrible job the players
did a horrible job we got our ass kicked
in that second half it sucked it stunk
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ]
i love that one
i thought i always thought he went yeah
fans sacked the defense sacked we sacked
oh [ __ ] now i can't shut this off
1976 stanley cup
the canadians vs the flyers oh that's
when larry robinson stood up to [ __ ]
dave schultz
and ended the broad street bullies and
sent them spinning back down to the
bottom
and here we are 46 [ __ ] years later
larry robinson destroyed that franchise
in one [ __ ] three-minute fight
um
anyway
so
i ate that [ __ ] food so i know i'm
not 179.8 at this point
um
so
oh and speaking of gyms
speaking of gyms this is something i'm
trying to just be positive so i'm done
with the [ __ ] you know
plastic water bottles but every once
every [ __ ] two years when i go to
wendy's evidently i'm gonna get some
giant [ __ ] i mean some kid could have
brought this [ __ ] plastic cup to the
beach and made a sand castle
hey people i'm telling you the cup was
big okay
um
i had like three sips of it
stupid
so
anyway i've been trying to uh
do something positive
as you know the news is telling me my
state's burning down
is 130 degree days it's snowing in
[ __ ] brazil
so i guess that that's what's gonna
happen we're just gonna have really cold
winters and really hot summers
and then we're all slowly gonna die is
that what they're telling me i can't
[ __ ] go out like that i gotta do
something positive here so
um
there's a few places
over the years
you know out here that i've gotten to
know
um
uh what am i trying to say here yeah
there's just some mom-and-pop places out
here that you know uh have written into
me or uh
you know comics i know are trying to do
some stuff uh some comedians i know
told me of this gym it's a mom-and-pop
gym
that's just been uh you know it's not
one of the big chain ones so they're
they're having some financial
difficulties uh it's called
bodybuilder's gym i believe that's what
it's called
and uh
they have a gofundme page save
bodybuilders jim
um they owe a bunch of money in back
rent
and uh they could use your help if you
got a little bit of money you could
throw it their way that'd be a positive
thing to do i guess
in the midst of all of this crap i just
want everybody know that i am rooting
for everybody at this point
okay i'm rooting for people that got
vaccinated and wear masks and i'm
rooting for the people that don't you
know
i hope i hope uh whatever the [ __ ]
you're you're breaking this [ __ ] down it
works out for you
um
i don't want to see any more people die
of this [ __ ] but you know
i don't know it's weird
it's just a weird thing it's also 130
degrees out so i mean i don't know i
don't know
see i'm trying trying to be pi i'm
trying hey football season's coming
everybody
we got that going forward too
as of today we are if you can believe it
we are one month away the longest off
season in the the top four the big four
professional sports is football season
basketball and hockey barely get any
time off it's july
august
september four months
from the stand of the stanley cup final
or the nba finals day before they start
back up again
um baseball ends
october and then what is it there let's
see them what is theirs theirs is uh
november december january february march
april i guess they go six months
sort of
do they yeah maybe they do
but football season
or maybe just feels the longest well
they they now play the first week of
february so march april may june july
august
march april may june july august
september it's almost seven [ __ ]
months
one of the saddest things in my life
other than most most of the major
decisions that i've made my life the
only thing sadder than that is how
quickly the regulus and if the nfl
regular season goes by
i mean just as you're getting settled in
all of a sudden they're talking about
the [ __ ] playoffs
playoffs
hey what is it 17 weeks
just flies by so as always
i'm gonna try and um
try and get to see as much as this as i
can it's been the upside of covid like
last year
i actually got to
be home every football sunday
probably for the first time since when i
used to live back in boston way back in
the day oh and speaking of that
um
i'm taking the old red eye back to
boston
on tuesday evening tomorrow evening so i
can uh
i could do the benefit for my buddy
wayne previty who passed away slash
benefit slash uh
you know reunion of all these comedians
that i started out with that are in and
around the boston area so many people
are flying in for this event
and it just really shows how much uh
wayne prevetty was loved by all of the
comics that knew him he's just such a
sweetheart
of a guy
and uh
he saved me from a couple of ass
kickings and bars
big guy big heart just a [ __ ] awesome
guy all of the proceeds are going to
speaking of hearts the american heart
association
um that fights hearts disease and all of
that crap so there we go and with that
no i didn't even copy and paste my
[ __ ]
advertisements did i
let's see here oh then we're going to
get into oh jesus christ
you know i asked the cyclists to write
in my god picking on cyclists is like
making fun of people that like harry
potter
you know i'm making fun of people that
watch marvel movies and [ __ ] you know
you just like making fun of them
you know feminists fat people all of
those [ __ ] overly sensitive [ __ ]
people can't take a goddamn joke you
know
it is what it is
um
yeah so i start picking on cyclists
right and all of a sudden they're coming
out of the goddamn woodwork
these people here's the thing about
cycling
all right
if they just kind of got rid of cars
or toned them all down to a massive in a
massive way for like cities i would not
have a problem with that
you know cycling around i guess i would
after a while i'm getting [ __ ] old
but i i don't have a problem with that
but they they
i don't know how you transition now
you know with the roads and all of that
crap i have no [ __ ] idea
i don't know i can just tell you there's
no you there's no [ __ ] way you'd ever
catch me on a bicycle
riding
in a town in a city anywhere everybody's
on their [ __ ] phones
weed is legal
i mean you understand there's people out
there
that wake and bake they wake up they get
[ __ ] high
and the thing about weed is is everybody
thinks it's this amazing drug
and they think it's not addictive now
i'm gonna get the weed people pissed at
me
um they think it's not addictive
they think they drive better when
they're high this is things like like
guys who get [ __ ] drunk and they
drive drunk they wake up the next
morning going like oh man i shouldn't
have done that [ __ ] i need to [ __ ]
slow down people who smoke weed are just
like dude i drive better when i'm drunk
yeah
i [ __ ] i'm more artistic
are you are you more artistic well you
should have somebody stone sober look at
your work when you're done
but have your fun
don't listen to me i'm just a grumpy old
sober guy now
[ __ ] gets excited about french toast
oh my god all right roman roman
everybody you know most guys have tried
different ways to last longer
but saying the pledge of allegiance in
your head oh by saying
not but by saying the pledges pledge of
allegiance
in your head i never understood why you
would do any of that
you know what i mean you say the pledge
pledge of allegiance in your head while
you're banging some woman trying not to
[ __ ] bust a nut and then what next
time you go to a sporting event and
somebody sings a national anthem you get
a semi you're like what the [ __ ] going
on with me
um
you got to go to therapy
american flag makes you dick hard now
you know can you imagine if that was if
that was a problem you had the american
flag made your dick hard i mean jesus
christ where could you go
honey could you take this down to the
post office i don't think that's a good
idea
why because i'm wearing sweatpants
uh the folks at roman and online's men's
health company are changing the game
with roman swipes the secret to longer
lasting sex sex sex sex roman swipes are
clinically proven
uh clearly proven way to last longer in
bed they're effective easy to use and
fast acting but don't require a
prescription
roman can ship swipes to you in a
discreet you know it comes too quick
it's not going to say that unmarked
packaging and each swipe packet is small
enough to hide in your wallet
for wherever you need it
uh well wouldn't you just be upfront
with the woman
just say listen i'm really attracted to
you as you can see okay but i want to
make sure that you know
i don't get knocked out of the game in
the first quarter
all right
so just hang on a second
dude i'd have like a magician's hat on
and i would cover up my dick with the
thing just like you know i might do one
of those dumb ass tricks
and then you [ __ ] pull it away voila
enjoy my numbed up dick uh swipes are
great they will not transfer to your
partner so you can last longer without
worrying oh good they don't transfer
because then you're both sitting there
like are we [ __ ]
uh they're super easy to use just take
the
swipes out of the packet swipe it on let
it dry and you're good to go that's it
go to
getroman.com and get 10 off your first
order of swipes plus free two-day
shipping that's
getroman.com for 10 off your first order
of swipes plus free two-day
shipping
all right
and with that oh my god am i gonna get
to these [ __ ] people
these goddamn people
hang on a second
there we go
oh i didn't copy and paste anything i'm
a [ __ ] idiot this week
as opposed to what bill every other week
all right take it easy
take it easy
somebody sent me this uh
this clip because i guess it's rocket
richard's
100th birthday
um
the great montreal canadien
and there's this great clip of him
talking about
how um
one time he showed up to the arena
before the game and he was tired and he
was dragging ass and the coach said you
look tired
and he was just like yeah you
so know
helping my brother move in
moved a bunch of furniture around and
all of this stuff so yeah i'm tired
so instead of giving the uplifting
speech
he just tore into rocket richard brown
professionally was and all of that and
then he went out there playing the red
wings and he ended up scoring five goals
and three assists
and
this the reporter or whatever the
interviewer tells the story
to rocket richard going is that true he
goes yeah it's true you know he's like
i've been you know moving the furniture
around we slept on the floor i only got
like three hours sleep
he's like yeah that's all true so first
of all what a good [ __ ] he is
he's a professional hockey player and
he's helping his brother move into an
apartment
you know
sleeps on the floor down to earth guy
and this how down to earth the guy is
in the end
when he was describing instead of saying
he got
he said i got five goals and two assists
he actually knocked down the point and
he said it was one of those lucky nights
where everything went in
called himself lucky and i'll tell you
right now that's the type of humility
that i don't see out there are these
goddamn social media [ __ ] thanks
there
all right
so here we go
it says great emails
bill great emails cycling [ __ ]
dear billy training wheels
a [ __ ] is a [ __ ]
whether you are driving a car or riding
a bike
why do you think cyclist [ __ ] are
cuntier than a lazy car
driving bald [ __ ] like you okay okay
let's let's look at that whole sentence
um i'm lazy because i drive a car
how does that make me lazy i guarantee
you buddy you're not working harder than
i am in life
you're not
okay
you're not so go [ __ ] yourself and then
secondly
like this is how you why you guys are
cuntier because i don't hold up 40
[ __ ] cars
behind me
and act like i don't know they're there
and i'm too much of a [ __ ] to just move
five feet over
you know i'm not saying that there's not
bad drivers out there i'm not even
saying that i'm not a [ __ ]
okay but there is
there is a scale here you know what i
mean
there's slapping your [ __ ] neighbor
and then there's robbing a bank
different jail sentences right
so i don't know how you think just
riding down the street like you're in a
bike race in the middle of the [ __ ]
lane and nobody can get around you and
you act like you don't notice that
there's 20 cars around you and you can't
just like you know when there's a moment
where the guy could go on the other side
of the road if you just moved over a
little bit and you just still don't do
it
yeah i would say that you're more of a
[ __ ]
and this is from a [ __ ] so i know one
when i see one anyway if there are no
bike lanes
bikes will be on the
road i don't mind that they're on the
road it's when you're in the middle of
the road
blocking the whole lane and there's no
bike lane
you're just blocking the whole [ __ ]
lane
that's what i'm talking about
these [ __ ] cyclists they keep acting
like they don't understand what you're
talking about
uh you should consider putting pressure
on your politicians to build more bike
lanes oh is that what i should do with
my free time
i should take up your cause
making the road safer for cyclists and
less annoying for angry [ __ ] like you
see this [ __ ] look at this
like i'm the [ __ ] problem here and
you guys aren't
um
all right i guess it's my fault i guess
it's my like i would be less of an angry
[ __ ] that's what that's like a really a
dr phil solution i'm not an angry [ __ ]
because of cyclists i have anger issues
from [ __ ] abuse when i was a kid
that's why i'm angry you dumb [ __ ]
all right and i guess you
going out there
in your little stupid outfit
blocking traffic
when i'm trying to pick my kid up at
school or i'm trying to get to a meeting
and you just won't move over a [ __ ] hair
and then you turn around and i give you
the peep i'm not even beeping at you i'm
giving to people like hey buddy just let
you know i'm here can you let me get by
and then you just turn around and give
me the finger
but like i'm the angry [ __ ] right
i don't know love from a
lycra i don't know what that is wearing
mostly law-abiding cyclists from berlin
germany well at least
and he goes please keep talking [ __ ]
about cyclists i love hearing your
podcast while causing traffic jams on
roads with bike without bike lanes
i know you guys seem to be really good
at that all right uh biker riding here
dear auntie biker bill i am not an
anti-biker i am anti staying in the road
with the funeral parent procession of
cars behind you i'm just asking
you [ __ ]
ballet slipperwear and [ __ ] to just
move over a little
don't you guys always yell share the
road
anyway i've been an urban cyclist
in the people's republic of seattle for
over 10 years
and have had hundreds of harrowing
encounters with cars pedestrians and
other bikers yeah i imagine the big
thing rather than getting run over which
is probably the worst
is uh people opening their car doors
after they
park i've had people do that to me dr
when i'm driving a car there are idiots
and or thoughtful individuals doing
everything but most of us or at least
half of us
okay
okay some of us
are just trying our best
dude i saw this morning i came down my
[ __ ] street
and right as i'm getting to the to the
uh
you know to be able to turn onto the
busy street i see literally 20 cyclists
in a row go by
all right and here's the deal they all
had these little flags in the back of
their cars cut out their bikes they all
had helmets on and they were dressed in
regular clothes and guess what they did
they rode on the side of the road and
there was no problem getting past them
and i was thinking like yeah that's how
that's how people used to do it
it's the new thing where you go all the
way out in the road
as you alluded to by saying people in
regular clothes are usually good shits
your empathy is admirable as always oh
god i think you set me up here the
people in toward a fan tour de france
tour de france always said gear taking a
lane just because they're [ __ ] and i
abhor them too well look at this but
sometimes you have to take the lane it's
safer than riding in the door zone
next to parked cars
okay that's fair enough
so if there's no parked car then i can
be upset
here in washington we adopted the idaho
stop last year
yeah i looked this up in california uh
cyclists has to come to a full stop at
stop signs at red lights which evidently
none of them know that here in
washington we adopted the idaho stop
last year which puts into law that
cyclists can treat stop signs as yield
signs
and stop lights
like stop signs
which means you'd have to come to a
complete stop look both ways and if it's
safe you can go
they've been doing this in idaho since
since the 80s and it has proven to
decrease traffic for motor vehicles and
bikes alike
as well as reducing collisions and
fatalities well then that's good then
i'm all for that
it all it's also how most bikers behave
anyway furthermore cyclists have killed
exactly zero people not including
themselves by running traffic lights
well dude that's the point
that's the point
is that you're going to run the light
and then somebody's going to come the
other way and then kill you and then for
the rest of their life they have to deal
with the guilt of that
so because they don't kill anybody that
they should be allowed to ride out in
front of people and then get themselves
killed and then the person has to
[ __ ] live with that
i don't know whereas over 38 000 people
die in car related crashes per year in
america so the onus is on them
to be more cautious
wow dude you really took a leap there
okay
so the
i would tell you this buddy
i am way more cautious if i'm riding if
i was to be riding a bicycle down the
street knowing that there's cars and
people texting
so uh
i don't think that riding around maybe
you're not saying this but it sounds
like you're saying that riding around
well it's not my job to be more careful
it's those people's jobs because they
could kill me
i feel like if you're the person that
could get killed you should be extra
careful
and not blowing through red lights and
stop signs even if it [ __ ] you know
reduces traffic which is not why you
guys do it you do it because you don't
want to [ __ ] take your little dancing
slipper out of the [ __ ] hook on the
on the thing there or whatever
um
any hope this wasn't too long
now finish your kale in watercress nut
smoothie
that actually sounds yummy after my
[ __ ]
goddamn foray into fast food last night
get your pasty fat ass on a bike and go
for a ride
um
no dude you wouldn't you wouldn't catch
me on a [ __ ] bicycle uh there's just
no [ __ ] way
there is i'll ride a bike's bicycle at a
beach where there's like a [ __ ] bike
lane i'll do that but there's no [ __ ]
way i would ever be dumb enough to ride
a bike down the street where the cars
are let alone dress up like i'm riding
in a bike race who wants to die dressed
like that
was this guy in a triathlon no he was
going to the post office
people sponsor that now
these people he's just giving he's just
this is just free advertising
um
anyway all right i'm gonna stop being a
[ __ ] i get it it's it's better for the
environment if people ride bikes and all
of that stuff so i respect cyclists but
can you just
can you if this if there's only one lane
and you're right in the middle of it is
there any way you could just [ __ ]
move over for half a second and if
somebody gives you a little peep just to
let them know they're there not give him
the [ __ ] finger
you know can you just [ __ ] do that
and i've even brought up when like you
when that sea of angry kids all decide
that they're all going to ride bikes
down the street and they get super
aggressive and start yelling at you as
you're sitting in your car like i don't
know what i did
[Music]
just
i'm just trying to get where i'm going
you know
just like a bunch of kids who were never
hugged by their parents
riding by in this mob
and then deliberately stopping traffic
like this is a protest
against what what your parents who
didn't [ __ ] hug you
all right let's see what those protests
are all about before i make another
bigger fool of my
bike
swarms
uh
i spelt it wrong bike swarms
swarms of dragonfly what do you write
bike
gatherings
stopping
traffic
block while writing group writing
the legal aspect
oh wait a second come on there's a whole
[ __ ]
it's a whole new world out here
all right blocking all this is what i've
wondered about
is this this is probably legal
uh whenever taking to the road
safety is often at the air for front of
our mind come on buddy
just get to the [ __ ] point this is
like one of these [ __ ]
it's like what he's [ __ ] you know you
look up you know how to make uh cinnamon
french toast
you know cinnamon and french toast the
people really don't know where the
origin is i don't care where it is
it's called french toast i'm guessing
it's from france if it isn't i don't
care
just tell me the ingredients
please
um
whenever taken to the road safety is
often at the forefront on writer's minds
maybe even more so when riding in a
group
staying together
dude there's literally so much
advertising i can't even read the words
here staying together on a long ride can
be challenging when maneuvering through
city streets and intersections one
solution
motorcyclists have found is block oh
this is motorcycles
it's a whole other [ __ ] can of worms
um
i wonder what happened if we all
switched to [ __ ] bikes
there's no way you could ever do it i
mean people won't even put on a [ __ ]
mask
for three minutes to walk into a
7-eleven to buy some beef jerky
without feeling like they're living
behind the berlin wall
and pouting and and gronk spiking a
gallon of milk i love when people do
that and then what am i supposed to
clean that up
is that what i'm supposed to do you
[ __ ] baby
all those phony patriots
i love all those people with the
american flag in their front yard and
they act like they're a patriot you're
so you're just a selfish [ __ ]
that's all that's all i'm really seeing
in all of this okay you're a selfish
[ __ ] you just want cheap gas and you
don't give a [ __ ] how many babies have
to die but when it comes time for you to
step up and do the right thing for your
countrymen all of a sudden you know
oh i don't trust the government uh love
it or leave it um anyway it's time for
california to legalize the safety stop
i'm not reading any of this [ __ ] i'm not
reading any more of this crap
um
all right where the hell am i this is
what happens when i don't copy and paste
my stuff here
all right
redhead at the gym
redhead at gym dear billy bald [ __ ]
uh today i saw the hottest guy a ginger
at the game and i immediately thought of
you lol yeah that's a joke uh because
you are one yourself holy [ __ ] look at
that getting a compliment
do you have any tips on approaching a
redhead the rarest of breeds thanks and
go [ __ ] yourself
um you know we respond to hello
i would say you know we might have a
surprise look on our face
you know
i'm just [ __ ] with you i mean i is
there a way i know you're just joking
around
um
i don't know why you just [ __ ] go up
there why don't you try out you i'm not
gonna [ __ ] write an opening line for
you how do you approach your redhead
uh so
what level sun blocks do you use um
oh good luck with that good luck with
you banging the hot ginger at the gym
uh redhead down oh look at this i'm
getting everything from cyclists to uh
redheads this week i like it i never
really reach out to my people
uh redhead down under
[Music]
i guess this might be my favorite one
hey billy [ __ ] tits
[Music]
i love profanity that doesn't really
even make sense but that it but that
also does
uh you said you never heard of the term
fanta pants on the last podcast i
haven't i've heard a fan of the soda
i've never heard of fan of pants on the
last podcast there's a fellow redhead
from australia
it's been thrown my way many times
before the fanta soda drink
being orange color
and pants referencing your pubes
oh my god that's hilarious it's a simple
dig that the curtains match the drapes
pretty much i like that fan of pants uh
growing up i never had much luck with
the ladies moved abroad to europe and
bam two weeks in met my now wife
together for five years with a beautiful
daughter i wasn't looking for the one at
the time but this is usually when it
happens to people supposedly uh so hope
that encourages other listeners to make
the move abroad if the fish ain't biting
locally yeah all of a sudden you got you
got an accent you're a world traveler
you're interesting
unless you're a mouth breathing [ __ ]
then you just embarrass your country um
also we just went on holiday
to bosnia
and
herzegovina it's a beautiful country
check it out one day love what you do
bill all the best to go [ __ ] yourself
um i actually was watching um the
women's 100 me uh what 10 000 meter race
which was unreal it was so [ __ ] hot
these women were just collapsing
i mean i've never seen like olympic
athletes just like tap out
like that it's just like this [ __ ]
i don't know i don't want to scare you
with the global warming but i mean you
would think that if you worked your
whole life for that moment you'd go
around the track enough you've obviously
ran 10 000 meters before they couldn't
even get through it
um but i was watching there was uh two
women from kenya i think and then one
woman from bosnia
and uh
i don't know i like watching those
endurance suffer fest
i also watched a little bit like the
first quarter of the women's gold medal
i missed the guys gold medal i watched
some of the swimming
um i don't know i really got into it i
really actually enjoyed the olympics
this time through um laughter band
um
by the way getting back to the other guy
that is such a big thing
i wish i did that when i was younger
if you just just go out and what you
know when the world becomes normal again
if it ever will if this is the new
normal um
yeah
you go travel somewhere and you got a
[ __ ] accent forget about it
you know you're like kevin bacon and
footloose
all of a sudden you're teaching a whole
town how to dance
uh laughter band dear billy boo
well people are going to call me billy
boohoo the man i'm going off on [ __ ]
cyclists
um dear billy boof i like billy boohoo
dear billy boohoo what are you bitching
about this week on the podcast
um i'll tell you what i'm bitching about
ever since i've signed up for watching
the red sox online they can't win a
[ __ ] game
they just lost three or four to toronto
they lost two or three to the tigers
they got swept by tampa
and i'll tell you the schedule doesn't
get any easier
we got tampa coming up we're now in
second place
um
but what's his face sale is uh rehabbing
i think he had to start last night in
triple a or something like that when he
gets back he'll be able to help us stop
the skip we'll get it going again
hey better to have a skid now than in
october doesn't everybody make the
playoffs now playoffs uh dear billy boo
a few months ago a reader wrote into the
podcast about censorship and some crazy
stuff that was happening at their kids
school last week i got a letter from my
kids school it was basically an outline
of what kids and parents
should expect going into the new school
year
all right tucked away in the middle of
the covid protocol and exci exciting
school activities with some new
guidelines on joke making
it essentially says that kids are not to
make any jokes and parents
should instruct children not to provoke
laughter
oh my god do you see what happens
do you see what happens when
unfunny people get a voice on social
media
wow they're going to get rid of class
clowns
i thought that this was maybe some
bullying related stuff and wrote it off
later in the week i ran to my neighbor
who has a kid in the same school system
he's a real nice guy and loaded and does
a lot of volunteering in town i.e
organizing leagues and raising money for
families who need help
real salt of the earth he tells me that
he ran into the principal at a recent
outdoor event and asked about the
bullying clause in the email
specifically if this was provoked by any
serious bullying of a child
the principal proceeded to tell him that
laughter had nothing to do with
education and jokes of all types were
offensive
this sounds like a bad movie
my neighbor asked if knock knock jokes
were okay and he said absolutely not
he he went even further to say that
teachers were instructed to discipline
any child who was laughing or being
silly
this is great i mean they are they are
creating the incubator for the next
generation of comedians possibly the
greatest comedians of all time
i had a hard time believing this so i
did some something i've never done nor
thought i'd ever do i called the school
and talked to the principal i had to
know for myself
this sounds like click bait
after a few questions about what
prompted the no jokes allowed policy he
accused me of being an educational
detractor who was promoting archaic
tendencies in my own children
what was your response ooh
big words
i wear a tie
uh because he said this to him he said
because i said that laughter is an
important part of life
even then quickly chained he then
quickly changed the subject and asked
what my political affiliation was i said
what
oh and a high screeching voice what
like you would say playoffs he responded
to my what by saying he had the ability
to contact child services if he felt any
child was in danger of mental abuse
wow yeah
this guy's handling his position of
power really well needless to say my
blood was boiling and i hung up the
phone i have a few ideas about how to
handle this i don't want to stir things
up but also it seems unwise to let
someone threaten me with child services
and call me archaic
for wanting my son to be able to laugh
and not be a drone while in school
how would you handle this
um
all right i don't want to handle this uh
i don't know
how do you handle this
how how how do you do this now with like
all of these [ __ ] people out there
that just
ruin all of this [ __ ] i don't know
i mean you can't
get your kid kicked out of school
i mean this sounds like a great click
bait piece
for uh a newspaper or something but that
always seems like a [ __ ] move to me to
just [ __ ] rat somebody out like that
um
i don't know you know what i would
actually do i think i might go above the
guy's head
and just say that i was simply i think
you have somebody who's wildly out of
control with his own power
i simply asked what you know
why my kid couldn't laugh in school
and he threatened to call child
protective services
first of all dude i i wouldn't i mean
it's the only thing that should make you
mad is the threat of that
that that he actually is just
threatening you but what are they gonna
do
they're not gonna do anything they can't
take your kids away because you
questioned why my son can't laugh at
school
he's gonna have no bruises or anything
like that
but it's that's that is a full-on
[ __ ] crazy person
is this real are you are you just
trolling me i can't believe this is true
if this is if this is a joke that's
really well written
i gotta look it up all right i'm ta i'm
you fished me i'm [ __ ] taking the
bait here
laughter ban in schools
speech code of the month
drexel university's harassment policy
bans inconsiderate jokes and
inappropriate
inappropriately jesus christ i'm done
inappropriately directed laughter
wow
mom i got suspended for three days for
inappropriately directed laughter
but where were you directing this
inappropriate laughter
i don't know i turned my head in the
face of the janitor i was looking away
from the fat kid and it turns out he was
missing a leg
i was i was trapped in a triangle
um
togenica laughter epidemic
what is this
the
tanganyika
laughter epidemic of 1962 was an
outbreak of mass hysteria i'm on
wikipedia now or mass
psychogenic
illness
rumored to have occurred in or near the
village
of
kashasha
nothing i've read in the last 20 minutes
has seemed real on the western coast of
lake victoria
in taganeeca
which was once united with zanzibar this
is none of this is true became the
modern nation of tanzia
near the border of uganda
history the laughter epidemic of what do
they have rabies on january 31st 1962 at
a mission run boarding school for girls
in cash
it started with three girls and spread
throughout the school affecting 95 of
the 159 pupils
other is the laughter epidemic obviously
a slang for whatever disease they had
symptoms lasted from a few hours to 16
days the teaching staff were unaffected
and reported that students were unable
to concentrate on their lessons
the schools closed on march 18th the
epidemic spread
to somewhere else a vigil where several
women lived mostly young villagers had
laughing attacks
all right what happened did somebody
light a giant [ __ ] bong in the cloud
went over over the this
true or false here we go laughing
epidemic true or false
it was no joke the 1962 laughter
epidemic
was no joke according to
some stupid website
the chicago tribune
oh jesus christ
this is the [ __ ] internet i i don't
believe anything on the [ __ ] internet
anymore
i just i just don't i i'm not gonna
[ __ ] sit here wasting my time looking
up
the laughter epidemic
did it happen
did it not happen
um what would i do with that guy um
well in a perfect world you could walk
up to
him and be like hey fatso or whatever
the [ __ ] he looks like hey baldy
you know
i don't know i would approach the guy
just like you know something you
threatened to call child services
you know i i got to be honest with you
dude i i never do this i would go above
that guy's head
and i would i would file a complaint and
what's the worst that's going to happen
your kid can't go to that [ __ ] school
[ __ ] this guy
[ __ ] this guy if this is actually real
[ __ ] that guy i would go above the guy's
head
and just say you know in a very calm way
you know
i mean that person should not have that
job
nor should they ever have any power
um i'm trying to think what happened to
that person
as a kid
you know what i mean
had man boobs it was shirts and skins
and gym class and they made him take his
shirt off some sort of uh
what was that that that movie where they
dumped the blood over the uh the prom
queen carrie this guy had some carry
[ __ ] happened to him
so now your kid can't have any joy
um yeah i would go over his head that's
what the [ __ ] i would do i would i would
not tolerate that
um
oh man that reminds me of a landlord of
mine that helped break into my apartment
when i was on the road
they they were checking
the smoke detectors and i was on the
road for three weeks so they had the
evidently the right to go into my
apartment
to make sure that there was no uh
you know there was nothing wrong with
this the you know smoke detectors
working because if they weren't there
was a fire it could affect the whole
building
so under that they came in
and uh i remember i came to my apartment
i just felt like something was wrong
because it was a notice but i just felt
and i just started looking around
and
uh
they had stolen a camera they had picked
through my cds they took some
knick-knack [ __ ] and i went downstairs
and told the guy
and the guy immediately goes you know i
don't appreciate you coming down here
accusing my staff that he immediately
got defensive and i was just like you
[ __ ] idiot now i know you did it
but there was really nothing i could do
i called the cops they said well unless
you have like
you know they dusted for fingerprints or
whatever they there's nothing they could
do
and uh so i just stood down there in
front of the office just told
a few people not to rent from there
that's all i had i was like dude i'm a
comedian i can do this all day and the
reality was i had to go on the road the
next day
so
my [ __ ] you to them was i changed the
locks and then i moved out
i moved out and then left the real lock
in the middle of the apartment but then
years later i realized well when they
couldn't get in they just called the
locksmith so the locksmith what i
basically did was i gave a locksmith
some money i cost them that money
and they never gave me my uh security
deposit back or anything there just was
a crooked [ __ ] place well that takes
me to a bad place all right let's plow
ahead overrated
dear billy cake belly
cake belly's good i love [ __ ] tits uh i
am currently on summer vacation in
greece good for you while driving near
the beaches i noticed a lot of people
mostly taurus
put out their hands and arms
through the window while driving and
doing stupid wave motions yeah maybe
it's an instagram thing but for me this
is the equivalent of people whistling
while walking
uh to demonstrate
to everyone hey look how look at me
look how happy i am this is one of the
stupidest things and most annoying
things i am currently seeing on a daily
basis and i am secretly hoping that an
upcoming truck or palm tree cuts
on of this country waving arms
all right
cuts off
country anyway love the podcast and wish
you and the your beautiful family all
the best
you know that's something i would do if
i was in greece on a vacation i would
allow something like that to annoy the
[ __ ] out of me so i i feel your pain
well you know how people are they
probably saw somebody else do it and
they're like i want to do what people do
and that's basically how people are you
know remember that planking
or flipping the water bottle
i actually didn't mind the flipping the
water bowl now i think about it because
it just took me back to the days before
video games
we just had to like entertain yourself
but then again people couldn't do it
without videotaping
videotaping themselves
i don't know people i
you know every time i think that i have
regained my sanity during all of this
[ __ ]
i go off the rails again and this is
this is one of them this has been one of
these podcasts so if you're concerned
about me i understand
and rightly so if you're just sitting
back laughing at me i also get that too
but um anyway
let's see who my [ __ ] red sox have
next
is it tampa
i think they were playing an afternoon
game today weren't they let's see red
sox score come on red sox
score red sox score
whoa
eight to four red sox there we go bottom
of the seventh let's turn the game on
looks like i missed everything toronto
blue jays go up one nothing after one
then the red sox come back with three
runs in the top of the second one run in
the top of the third blue jays get one
back four to two
three more runs top of the seventh they
must have their [ __ ] the fifth guy in
the rotation the blue
um
to make it uh let's see there that would
be
seven at two
and then of course blue jays get two
more seven of four then we get one eight
to four
what is it right now it's the bottom of
the seventh
do i dare turn it on bill for the love
of god you're the [ __ ]
the mush
don't turn it on i'm turning it on
watch this nobody out runners on second
and third
all right here we go
bottom of the seventh
turn the [ __ ] turn the thing right
now
let me see my red socks
oh no
oh jesus
oh this this this son of a [ __ ]
vladimir guerrero's son is up
this guy's a beast they got a runner on
first base
is there anybody out
ah when he throws a [ __ ] pass ball
jesus christ the second i turn it on it
is me
all right just hang out with me for half
an inch shall we
runner on second base he's even looking
around like i can't [ __ ] believe that
guy just threw the ball that bad
oh i know this guy this is this japanese
guy this guy's throws [ __ ] gas i love
this guy
i've been watching for six whole games
i love how the mullet's coming back
look at these batters could they have
more [ __ ] protection look at the guy
looks like he's peeking out of a phone
booth
he's covering up his whole jaw
all right alex cora he's wearing a mask
you know look at that
he's coming around
where'd you get that mask out of a trash
can
all right what do we got here comes the
pitch and it's in the [ __ ] dirt he
goes to third base bill shut the [ __ ]
game off can't do it
i can't do it what are we doing here
all right
alex just called on the black guy who
yelled throw the damn towel
in [ __ ] rocky throw the damn towel
called his son and uh oh
and a catcher hurt his wrist
vladimir guerrero jr is going you know
we're going to win this game right i
mean you guys you guys are going to lose
we think we're going to lose yeah yeah
jesus
oh jesus christ
they're talking what are we doing here
is there a reason you're throwing it
into the dirt for some [ __ ] reason
we're trying to win
oh it bounced up and caught him on the
wrist
come on guys
how many outs are here
what do we got here
zero outs
runner on third base
well that's it for him
well i usually pitch as well everybody
has a bad day i had a bad podcast today
all right
yeah one guy one guy said good game good
game two guys good game
all right now that's okay now they're
going to change pictures so this is
going to take an entirely different here
comes the guy ah [ __ ] i thought i had an
i thought i had the night off
the red glove because it matches my
socks
all right
i'm just doing this because i know
somebody's going to find this [ __ ]
footage
i didn't know you could switch it you
can switch pictures in the middle of it
in a bat i didn't know you could do that
i thought he had to get hurt
all right that's it
there's some woman who just caught
sunlight in a [ __ ] pot all right i'm
done with this [ __ ] okay that's the
podcast everybody
uh why would people be capturing
sunlight
during global warming
are they catching capturing the breeze
is this what was in the briefcase in
pulp fiction now i'm into this
commercial
keep it golden
power down
four to nine
nobody's gonna do that
they won't wear masks you think they're
not gonna have their air conditioner
it's my it's my [ __ ] god-given right
to keep my balls nice and frosty from
four to nine go [ __ ] yourself
this is america all right that's it
everybody um
i'll check in on you on thursday go [ __ ]
yourselves go red sox for the love of
god go red sox uh
and i will talk to you on thursday all
right enjoy yourselves try to be
positive
you know
i don't know why you listen to this
podcast if you're trying to be positive
but uh you know hang in there all right
i'll see